all right Tracy Tracy uh where'd you
grow up where you from originally I grew
up in a little Kim Colorado and tell me
about your childhood yet both your
parents is it yes yes yes until I was
about 16 17 years old and we my dad took
good care of us we never once lived in
an apartment or anything like that we
always had a four or five bedroom house
front yard back yard you know my dad was
an auto body and fender man you know an
automotive division you know you know
automotive you know with cars and stuff
and we always went waterskiing on the
weekends in the summertime and you know
we did a lot of snow you know sports in
the you know wintertime and we had you
know we had a lot of fun then you know
my parents they you know in the
automotive division in the automotive
business you know my dad's friends they
were all bikers you know what I mean
brothers fast and you know so you know
you know we lived in nice houses and
stuff like that it wasn't you know all
tore up you know you know you know nasty
like women kings real nice houses and
stuff and but you know my dad he smoked
pot my mom smoked pot and so at a young
age that was always around me and at a
young age I started smoking pot and
drinking alcohol and then by time I was
16 17 years old I was a real bad
alcoholic you might say a minor
alcoholic and I couldn't handle my you
know alcohol I'd always come home on the
weekends with a black eye or something
you know from kegger parties and stuff
like that and you know I was just
totally out of control I used to tear my
dad's house up you know after my parents
got divorced you know and he just got
tired of my [ __ ] and he said pack your
[ __ ] and get out of here and I pack my
[ __ ] and I left and I went down to San
Diego was down there for a little while
his best friend's house from high school
that only lasted you know a couple weeks
and I left there so I started my journey
up the state of California and you know
I was in Carlsbad California Oceanside
for about four months just you know
hanging out on the beach just you know
being a beach bum and then I got tired
of that and I ended up in Las Vegas for
a little while and from there I heard
Hollywood and you know I didn't really
know much about Los Angeles really I
didn't know anything about Los Angeles
and there I was standing on Sunset
Boulevard looking down the boulevard and
it just went forever and he just never
ended you know and I was scared I was
really scared and I met this prostitute
and we went to her hotel room and we
spent a little time together and I left
and I was just hanging out on the
streets you know panhandling so on and
so forth and I ran into her again we
went to her house and gained her little
hotel room and we kicked it for a little
while and she offered me a place to stay
she could see that I was scared you know
I was young I was only like about 18 19
years old and so she kindly taught me
everything about the streets you know
how did you know
you know hustle people how to deal with
them and you know how to work a mother
excuse my language how to work a person
out of their money and so on so forth
and so one night she took off and to go
pull some dates and she never came back
so I figured well she's in jail you know
she's gonna write me and this and that
and you know I kept the rent paid by
selling weed to uh you know the host on
the host show her girlfriends and I
never got a letter from her anything you
know so I figured well maybe she's dead
you know and so I just continued on with
my life and I got caught selling two
joints to a female who was a police
officer and I didn't sell her no to join
so I gave her to join
and she handed me $5 and she said that's
for you and your friend can get some
beer and I said no I'm fine we got we
got our own money that's just for you
for free and she took off and then the
whole parking lot filled up with police
cars and so off I went to LA County Jail
and then from there I went to corporate
state prison when they first opened up
was three years they gave me the max
three years for selling two joints and
now it's illegal that three years ended
up being 33 years of incarceration back
and forth new terms to new numbers and
they basically stole my whole life away
from me just for two joints you know now
I'm off of parole I have my own place
and you know I I was so beat up by the
systems by CDC you know just in and out
of San Quentin I've been to Pelican Bay
new Folsom Corcoran you know all cala
patria i've been to all these prison
yards and you know to tell you the truth
man you know when people say that on
like convict you know so what that don't
really mean nothing man it just means
achievement locked away from society for
many years on the cookie sheet you know
you know you had nothing coming you know
and a lot of people that are in prison
they have something coming it's just
they're just being so you know used and
abused by CDC just taking their life
away for these petty ass crimes that
really ain't about [ __ ] you know but
that's how society is so I went to
recovery and I was involved in house in
2000 and I wanted to be in an ironworker
and that's what I began just being an
ironworker and I worked on it for about
two years and I relapsed and I told my
boss he you know I got to go it's not
safe for me being around all this heavy
machinery and he goes man just go back
to work and I go I relapse and he goes I
know I don't give a [ __ ] about that just
go back to work and I said no I'm gonna
go back to my addiction
and I picked up my checking back to my
addiction I went that was the biggest
mistake I ever made my life you know and
so I carried on in my addiction going
back and forth on violations and so on
and so forth and I finally got off of
parole I get all of it you know and then
caught another number and get all of
that one and now I'm free I don't know
them people nothing you know they don't
owe me nothing you know I'll never get
nothing from them for all the years that
they stole from me because my own
stupidity of not showing up on my parole
dates and stuff but you know I'm I'm
better now I got you know little things
working for me they're not you know too
terrific but you know you got to crawl
before you walk and you know you know I
I just had a bad addiction to met that
said I mean slamming that that said me
and my girlfriend got killed somebody
killed her and you know dumped her body
along side of the freeway and that was
enough for me I said I'm gonna stop and
I stopped using that and then I used
heroin to get away from the crystal no
are you setting all to get away from the
heroin and now I'm trying to kick the
fentanyl week ain't easy you know but
each day and time and she does it you
know and so you know my life has been
you know just back and forth back and
forth in and out these cages and this
and that and you know not too much life
left you know what 57 years old now you
know and everybody says well you look
like your life 37 you know that's
because when you're locked up it
preserves you and you know but I don't
feel it on the inside you know so now I
got me a little job over here at this
hotel I clean up the you know restrooms
and
you know common areas and you know I
live there for free and you know I do my
thing and all my friends there and you
know pretty much that's it for the days
you know but uh you know I can say that
you know these kids that come to these
streets you know I wish they really knew
what was ahead of them you know before
they get caught up in CDC which I don't
think CDC's as bad as it was now back in
the day because you know Arnold
Schwarzenegger kind of changed
everything and kicked out a whole lot of
lifers and this and that which it was a
good thing but you know these streets
will take and chew you up in a second
you know a couple years you won't have
no teeth and so on and so forth and
you'll be looking like you're 85 years
old you're only 25 you know and you know
people get so intention to their hustle
from the streets they don't realize that
they're hustling you know a person when
they're not really trying to but they
are and you know he just you know it
sets off a lot of feelings with people
and how they've been caught up and this
and that and what they went through were
it had to you know trick-trick with
their own race I throw on race but their
own you know gender and stuff like that
to make money and so on and so forth
just to survive when they really didn't
have to do that because I wasn't gonna
die in the first place I just wanted the
money for they could go get high you
know and other than that you know cool
moves the lowest point of your life the
lowest point of my life I don't know the
lowest point of my life is where I was
having the most fun you know with my
addiction you know I found out a long
time ago you know that it's not that
hard to you know seeking an addiction
matter of fact you can make it work for
you you know
and I mean you know you can sell crystal
and all that there's really no money in
in it anymore it's just uh you know it's
just pay for your high and you know
accumulate you know few signals around
you you know and you know but the lowest
has been I don't know what the really
Louis is I know I've been really bad in
my addiction to her every time I get a
shot and then Isis like man makes me
feel like [ __ ] you know I want to get
off this stuff so bad and thank God I
had the strength to get off of it you
know and the heroin what was the best
point of your life
the best part of my life that's to come
right now I just got put on Social
Security and I'm getting a nice little
fat retro and I'm gonna go buy me a nice
four-wheel drive pickup and buy me a
brand new yz250 and I'm gonna go to
these tracks and do what I've always
wanted to do since I was a kid you know
this ride dirt you know on an epic ride
good fear what do you think about your
childhood needs led you down this path
well my childhood was a good childhood
my dad gave me everything I wanted you
know if I wanted a motorcycle he got me
a motorcycle might not been the kind
that I wanted but he got me one
you know dad can I have a pool table and
he got me a pool table you know the only
thing that I didn't get was a swimming
pool in the backyard you know what I
mean but uh you know we always had jet
boats you know water skiing and stuff
like that and you know I had a good good
childhood I went to Kent Carl junior
high school and Columbine in high school
yeah the one that was wrong TV for the
shootings and stuff and you know it was
predominantly white you know we didn't
have really too many other races at the
at that school and there was a lot of
tension there between the jocks and the
stoners and that's what created that
singing Columbine and I think you know
because I know I went through a lot of
peer pressure when I was going through
you know high school and stuff but uh
you know I had a good good childhood you
know would use it can you put a finger
on anything about your your youth that
made
but you where you are now yeah when I
was five if I had a sister that was
three had and sister and we was being
babysitted all my appearances
anniversary and my sister got ran over
by a car and she died in front of me and
I always thought it was my fault you
know I told her to watch out for the
cars and I should have been more aware
of what I was saying to her than her
being aware of what I was saying to her
you know and you know our babysitter was
busy smoking my mother's cigarettes and
stuff you know then watching us you know
and my sister got hit by a car and she
died you know that was I've always taken
that upon my shoulders that it was my
fault you know I just recently talked to
my brother after 30 years after I've
left home because I was a burden to the
family and I just was a bad alcoholic
always controlling just you know just
out of control and my little brother
told me first thing he said he says hey
Tracy it wasn't your fault I said my
fault about what he was about Wendy and
he never even knew Wendy he wasn't even
alive when Wendy was alive and you know
so he never got to know her and you know
it kind of really touched my heart that
he said that and I talked to my brother
about every other day now we you know
he's doing good he's raised two child
two daughters since I left home and
fully grown girls and uh you know he's
doing his thing you know he's doing good
he's a truck driver for McDonald's he
delivers you know their produce and all
that stuff for me and all that stuff you
know around you know Colorado
you know like out in Wyoming and
you know Nebraska and stuff like that
and makes a hundred thousand a year you
know he's doing good
he doesn't even look like my little
brother anymore matter of fact he looks
older than I do you know like I said
prison preserves you know yeah how old
were you and your sister I was five she
was three she got hit you know she she
would have been you know she would have
been a hell a hell of a woman if she
would have made it you know she would
have never been hit you know my mom told
me that you know God had a special place
for that he needed her and I never could
understand that you know why does he
need her if he has so many dead people
on his list you know and that was a
major loss to our whole family because
you know you know how things pivot
around females and you know our whole
family was just pivot around her because
she was so funny all the time and you
know always in a good mood and she used
to come and give me food in the back
window when my mom would send me to
dinner was gonna send me to bed without
no dinner so I've been bad and enjoying
so fortunate here she come with a whole
armful food for me you know she was you
know she's my sister you know do you
feel like maybe that kind of setup
accepted your path in a different
direction yeah that's what you know I
just you know deep inside we don't
really realize that you know these
things we hold on to and it makes a big
difference in our lives and you know
that's what I've been taught going
through walls and house and stuff and
you know I held on to it I still hold on
to it you know and you know I just never
really knew how to deal with it you know
it's just you know deep inside you know
it hurts you know to know that you know
she was there at one time and now she's
gone you know I've always wondered what
her life would have been like if she
would have made it
you know she would still be alive you
know then my brother came into the
picture and I kind of had resentments
towards him you know taking her place
because I wanted my sister back and I
couldn't have her back and he knows he
knows that you know but he also knows
that I love him very much did you have
hope now for your your future from here
well I don't know how much future I got
he's on 57 years old now you know I've
been killing locked up in LA County Jail
since I've been 19 years old back and
forth back and forth back and forth to
her you know when they would go to
release me I'm just like why you guys
releasing me you're just gonna bring me
right back you know because you know I
had that number you know and uh you know
they basically warned my ass out real
good I don't do nothing I don't break
into cars and I don't sell dope I don't
use nothing I just work my little job
and a little hustle on the side and now
I got a little bit of money to work with
from SSI and so I'm gonna go do my thing
that's right dirtbike you know do you
feel like living here in the Tenderloin
is is a dangerous place for you to be
hanging out no it's not it's not
dangerous you know you know one person
can only make it dangerous to yourself
if they don't watch themselves if they
just let themselves go and just don't
give a [ __ ] about nothing and just let
themselves go and be using abuse by
other people because other people out
there will use you and abuse you other
people in their their addictions and
stuff you know and I feel that uh what
was the question again
no just I just wonder if being in this
neighborhood Tenderloin where there's
drugs everywhere yeah makes it harder
for you to deal with your traditional no
not really
he's just kind of like you know I was
thinking well now I don't have a prison
number you know what if I just keep my
motorcycle and leave and like truck and
leave you know then what am I gonna do
then I'm out of this County and if I get
busted for something they sure know how
we're gonna you
you know wrapped me up some years
because in my record you know but uh you
know with five turns and stuff so
probably better off staying here you
know I don't really feel that the
tenderloins a stretch maybe because I
know everybody and everybody knows me
and you know there are some people out
there they just flat-out don't like me
but that's their own personal feelings I
haven't did nothing to them and they
just keep it to themselves you know but
you know survival in the Tenderloin is
very easy compared to Hollywood
Hollywood it's where all these young
kids go and they're you think you're
gonna go go Holly wouldn't be a movie
star or a rock-and-roll star and they're
gonna show their parents and they're not
gonna buy their parents anything and
they're gonna be rich and they find out
to the hollywood is just nothing but a
ghetto it's for drugs and pimps and hoes
and you know gangsters and you know drag
queens and [ __ ] like that
you know and you know the street of
broken dreams you know Hollywood has
gotten nobody anywhere no there's a few
that made it you know you know a lot of
these rock and roll you know
stars like Axl Rose and stuff like that
we're on the streets you know in LA you
know through a lot of their songs and
their lyrics come from is like you know
living under the bridge and you know
dancing with mr. brownstone don't know
what that is you know all right Tracy
well thank you so much for sharing your
story yeah
and good luck with wherever you go from
here uh-huh thank you thank you I didn't
want to do something like this for a
long time oh good I think it's
therapeutic yeah yeah it's very
therapeutic do you ever get a chance to
talk about this with anybody yeah I
talked to my caseworker in my counselor
all the time about this stuff I've
talked to her so many times and it's
just you know I don't know what to say
anymore if we start covered everything
you know what's her you know I think
that's why they put me on exercise
because I have so much you know
background of being you know neglected
used and abused and
as a child and you know my mom used to
beat me pretty bad when I was before
Wendy was born and when Wendy was born
she she could beat on me so there was a
you know you know witness song she
couldn't doing that and you know she
didn't beat me really bad but she beat
me and locked me in a room for days
while my dad was out on the road truck
driving and stuff all right all right
thank you so much
you